Rangers find the carcass of yet another
rhinoceros killed by poachers in Kruger
National Park Frick Rosso and his
forensic team from the South African
National Parks Authority hunt for clues
of the killer's identity Rosso has
conducted autopsies on about one and a
half thousand rhinos and elephants you
can get used to a lot of things you can
get used to the smell the data animals
that you find but it makes you angry
meaning they would do animals kill deer
only for their haunts suspected poachers
who are caught are often tried in a
court house inside the park hundreds of
cases are heard here every year the
conviction rate is high more than half
the culprits come from Mozambique the
country is a hub for the illegal trade
in rhino and elephant ivory worldwide
poaching is a serious crime in South
Africa the punishment is severe average
kind of sentence for a poacher who was
found in possession of rhino horns and
an illegal firearm and also shot at the
ranges ranges between 30 and 50 years
imprisonment people living in villages
outside the park are poor ivory
smugglers often persuade young men there
to hunt for them with the promise of a
few hundred dollars they don't mention
the risk of imprisonment I mean I get to
go home after 10 or 20 or 30 years
leaving the family devastated was
absolutely no income because to the best
of our knowledge the crime bosses then
don't don't worry about the family rhino
poaching has been booming last year
almost 1,200 rhinos were killed in
Kruger National Park the demand for
rhino horn in China and Vietnam is high
1 kilogram there sells for up to 60
thousand dollars as long as there's a
monetary value attached to things like
rhino horn and ivory the problem won't
go away whether that monetary value is
illegal value or whether it's it's
legalized it doesn't matter as long as
it's there the problem will still
continue
there are an estimated twenty thousand
rhinos left in all of Africa thirty
thousand worldwide poaching presents a
very real threat to their survival